[Musik]
etwas glaubt jetzt willkommen beim ein
video
ich sitze gerade ein t shirt weil 18
grad
es ist auf jeden fall nicht so waren die
sonne deswegen musste ich mich heute
ganz besonders viel bewegen geht die
cool ihren und schnell reden viel reden
obwohl besser nicht und steht wieder in
kommentaren ab minute 449 geht's los
dank mir später ein paar fans willkommen
zumal ein video ich weiß ich hab grad
nicht bei sondern zugesagt erstmals und
vati mir heute folgendes thema überlegt
jetzt wahrscheinlich am titel auch von
gelesen ja ich habe mir einfach von euch
auf netapp witziges verläufe mit eurem
partner oder einer partnerin schicken
lassen und da schauen wir jetzt gleich
mal rein also es geht um die witzigsten
zwischen pärchen sehr kreativ schweiz
aber was ab es wird auf jeden fall
witzig also wenn ihr das nicht mal auch
das auf keinen fall verpassen wollt dass
sie mir sowas schicken können dann
steckt auf jeden fall meine mails
captial ab ich habe gehört da finden
auch auf uns zu in zug und coole
verlosungen statt die man auf keinen
fall verpassen deutet also bevor ich
vergesse wenn ihr bock habt auf platz
zwei lassen dann nach oben da ich würd
sagen was neben den heute bei 13 1731
likes gibt's platz zwei liegt also auf
jeden fall eine menge zu ich bin
gespannt also chef verlauf nummer eins
haben wir hier und zwar schreibt wie
lust auf ein spielchen daraufhin er klar
dann wie ok pass auch wenn mir eine zahl
zwischen 1 und 50 erschöpfen 30 wie gut
beschreiben mich in drei wörtern
liebevoll wie gestört jetzt bist du dran
50 ok moment schick mir bild von der ms
das ist auf jeden fall ein sehr schönes
spiel weiß ich in zukunft denkt auch das
ein oder andere mal spielen werde afrika
der ganzen welt also an die personen die
mir das geschickt hat wenn ihr das sieht
dann habe ich doch mal bitte darüber auf
wie das weitergehen natürlich total süß
eingespeichert meiner herrchen auf jeden
fall schreibt sie wärst du gerade ein
stein an meinem fenster das war früher
einmal so dass dann so irgendwie kann
man auf jemanden gewartet hat
steine dagegen über hoffenheim kam durch
die person auch die man gewartet als
junge auf dem fenster geklettert und hat
nur die bettlaken einander gemacht und
dann hat dieses verhalten runter
geschwungen und dann kam halt eher der
typ und hat diese in arm genau und dann
sagt sie sogar ich habe dich vermisst
dann sei also ja ich hab's ja auch warm
ist dann schießt mir sich so und dann
hauen wir ab und dann kommt doch okay
ich habe eindeutig zu viel übte auf
jeden fall ärgern ja wieso die wurzel
gibt's ein handy habe ich verstanden
handys gibt um zu schreiben um das
nachzuschauen um sich zu amüsieren um um
nacktbilder übers netz zentrum zu
schicken um für die schule zu lernen um
in der schule auch mal was nachts
übungen und wird auf jeden fall er
danach sind warten und dann schreibt sie
das passt jetzt nicht gemacht oder du
bist so ein idiot
und das hat dann einfach nur noch ein
haken also ist halt nicht angekommen
weil das handy vielleicht kaputt
gegangen ist so wir machen natürlich
weiter und war hier mit einer der beiden
beziehungspartner schreibt sommer schatz
ich liebe dich zwar immer noch aber ich
glaube nicht dass noch zwischen uns
funktioniert darauf hin dass er
wahrscheinlich ist dass gerade dein
ernst wirkte zwei jahren beziehung jetzt
einfach so wegwerfen und das dann auch
noch über website wie alt bist du bist
echt weiter das sollte man echtes machen
über rotten beziehung beendet von das
beste curry habt dann die falsche person
steht und er dann so ok ich das schon
schatz dann hat man halt anfangen kurz
mal nachgedacht und dann kam der moment
mal dein scheint er was bist du denn für
ein meer aus so jetzt hab ich das ganze
falschen vorgetragen sie schreibt dann
was das duell für eine an wen willst du
hast den schicken und dann schreibt er
da kann man schon echte daran zweifeln
ob das echtes will ich meine damit sowas
zustande kommt müssen sie es schon zwei
ziemlich dumme menschen getroffen haben
komm jetzt wechsle ich mal kurz die
seiten auf jeden fall haben wir was von
honigkuchenpferd
honigkuchenpferd hört sich irgendwie xx
einem absorber übrigens das schiff kein
jet verlauf zwischen zwei personen in
einer beziehung sind sondern zwischen
zwei freundinnen also auf jeden fall
schreibt die person die in einer
beziehung ist
ich bin so stolz auf meinen freund ihre
freundin fragt wieso und wie schreibt er
war letztens so betrunken dass er mich
mich erkannt hat und dann die freundin
so he und wieso bist du darauf steuer
als ich ihn dann küssen wollte sagt er
stolz
ich habe eine freundin und ich bin treu
also hat er sich nicht einmal erkannt
toller freund in zum teil habe ich echt
gestörte zuschauer ich weiß nicht wie
man auch so was kommt beziehungsweise
wie man wird auf die interne besser die
wirklich auch im tollen set verlauf und
zwar ganz süß schafft eingespeichert
warum auch immer die frage kommt warum
willst du nicht mehr mit mir zusammen
sein als antwort kann
kennst du das gefühl wenn du dich im bus
an einer stange fällt ist dann aber doch
nicht tust beide weit was 100 andere sie
angefasst haben willst du mir damit also
sagen dass ich eine [ __ ] werden
daraufhin er gut kombiniert das hätte
ich auch in meine letzte folge die
heftigsten körbe von jungs an mädchen
fahren können wenn ihr das was ich
gesehen habe dass auch mal in der video
beschreibung verlinkt so wir machen
weiter keine ahnung hat kein bild aber
das kann man hier ausstellen
liebst du mich ja natürlich da beweist
es mir als töchtern machen kämpft gegen
einen mögen was redest du denn da ging
ein hirn hab's doch gar keine chance
wer was anderes und film zeigt mir ein
nutzer wohl versagt
die wanne fiege das könnt ihr dann ganz
eventuell darauf schließen dass er dir
etwas verheimlicht aber muss natürlich
auch nicht sein ja ich bin kommt zum
letzten chat verlauf der kommt von lars
leese heißt der junge wollen jetzt nicht
noch einmal probieren darauf mehr nein
das wäre besser für uns beide
wenn wir es lassen praktisch aber warum
denn und er daraufhin bestimmt nicht in
der wohnung
das waren jetzt erstmal ein paar chat
verläufe what's up dad verläuft zwischen
zwei partnern die zum teil echt sehr
amüsant findet also schickt mir auf
jeden fall noch eine menge weitere zu
bei 13.700 27/33 keine ahnung ihr wisst
bescheid der zweiten partie erzielt ab
wir sehen uns dann am freitag wieder
weiter kind für neues video weit
gespannt ich freue mich natürlich sehr
auf euch und ja ich wünsche euch noch
einen angenehmen abend oder wann auch
immer ihr dieses hier schaut